what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
man let me tell you some man it's been a
little while since I got this excited
about a story a Green Lantern blackest
night con heaven okay so so those you
guys who were just catching up with us
the long and short of it is that you got
all these Lantern course that all tie
into the emotional spectrum look at
through all that stuff as we go through
this story there's another Lantern core
called the black lanterns and it's
basically just black rings showing up
seemingly out of nowhere and then
resurrecting all these dead heroes
that's the long and short of what we've
covered so far now the cool thing about
this is that all the heads of the
Lantern cores which is to say the
individuals who were basically either
the leaders of the cores or considered
to be the most powerful of the cores
have all banded together for the purpose
of preventing this war of light the way
the prophecy of blackest night played
out in the Green Lantern mythos is that
there was this idea that the seven
Lantern course all these Lantern cores
were gonna rise and they were just gonna
go to war against each other for
whatever reason but while they were
waging war the black lanterns would show
up with their rings they would start
resurrecting all these dead heroes and
so while the lanterns were paying
attention on what was going on all these
dead heroes would just start spreading
throughout the entirety of the universe
and then the entire emotional spectrum
would be obliterated the Lantern cores
would be destroyed and the universe
would just go into this age of darkness
that's the prophecy of the black
Lantern's so all these Lantern Corps
showing up they're all basically banding
together to say okay let's face off
against these black Lantern's now here's
the cool thing if this story was written
in Marvel it would just be this massive
Universal crossover like annihilation DC
is not that way DC does not have this
huge universe or wide pantheon of
different things they basically have the
Green Lantern's whatever race they
happen to come across and then like
that's basically it but DC is like you
know Universal Pantheon is nowhere near
as huge and developed as Marvel is and
so wanted to keep in mind is that these
black Lantern's spreading throughout the
universe we just kind of left to assume
they're spreading to other planets all
throughout the cosmos but a bulk of the
conflict is following whatever Green
Lantern core members are in space and
then earth earth is like where the
biggest brunt of that stuff happens now
the whole idea is that every single
member of the Lantern Corps I guess
every every part of the emotional
spectrum which is to say all the Lantern
cores have an entity Necron is like the
emotional aspect of death if death could
be an emotion the whole idea here is
that when it came to the various
superheroes who have died over the years
one of the big questions people had is
if these superheroes have died how are
they alive now well the great thing
about this is that Geoff Johns comes
along and he says okay
these superheroes actually died and this
conversation this whole you know
taunting by William hand and neck Kron
is so on what we end up learning is that
Barry Allen was supposed to have died
during the events of crisis on Infinite
Earths when he broke down on a molecular
level he was supposed to go to the
afterlife he was supposed to be dead
nekron got in their way and stopped him
from dying and sent them back and that's
how they lived now the other half of
this was remember the only real
spacefaring force that's capable of
dealing with these black Lantern's
as a Green Lantern Corps and like we
covered in previous videos they're
dealing with the black Lantern's off
into space and so it's basically just
the Earth's superheroes so we have like
the Teen Titans and the Justice League
and all these different superhero groups
that come together to try to face off
against Necron and all these black
Lantern's remember this is almost like a
losing war right like these guys it's a
stopgap measure that's all it is it's
them jumping in and trying to destroy
these Black Lantern rings because
remember the only way a Black Lantern
ring can truly be destroyed is if a
massive amount of light from multiple
sources is basically just thrown at
these black lantern ranges so you'd have
to have somebody like dr. light who can
manipulate light you have to have like
multiple cores coming together and
firing all their rings at the same time
and channeling those energies in order
to destroy them and the whole idea of
channeling their energies comes to bear
for the various leaders of the Lantern
course to basically put their energies
together into the black lantern central
power battery remember the black
Lantern's central power battery like all
the other central power batteries is
basically where the black Lantern's get
their power from so the whole idea is if
they destroy the central power battery
it'll do two things the first is it'll
basically deactivate all the black
lantern links and the second is it'll
send necron back to his own realm
whoever it was that he came from the
problem is it doesn't work because it's
so much power and so much energy it's
almost impossible to do and so what is
up happening here and probably one of
the greatest moments in the history of
comics these rings start flying out one
of them says Bruce Wayne of Earth rise
so Bruce Wayne like Bruce Wayne nor
Bruce Wayne's dead and ends up coming
back and is one of the coolest things
now remember this is not really Bruce
Wayne like it's not really the essence
of Bruce Wayne the spirit of Bruce Wayne
it's his body it's basically the Black
Lantern rings reconstituting Bruce
Wayne's body and then using it as a
vector but when it comes to Bruce Wayne
he is probably one of the single most
important characters in
all of the DC landscape for a bunch of
different reasons one of the first
reasons is because of the fact that
everyone is tethered to him and that's
why he was brought back but the whole
idea is that whether they trust him
whether they don't trust him whether
they love him whether they hate him
everybody in some former fashion is
connected emotionally to Bruce Wayne and
so because of this using this emotional
tether of Bruce Wayne in the shock of
the moment all of these guys are
basically bonded with Black Lantern
rings and we end up with the Black
Lantern Justice League the only
exception to this is Hal Jordan and
Barry Allen at this point we switch over
to Jon Stewart now Jon Stewart is one of
those Green Lantern's where he basically
achieved the height of his popularity
during the Justice League cartoon show
he breach aids that show by like 30
years but he was just one of those Green
Lantern's out there and in the end
despite the fact that he was introduced
back then despite the fact that he was
amazing it didn't much matter because
the Green Lantern titles weren't selling
anyway but with the Justice League
cartoon show he was the only Green
Lantern on that show as it was a way to
just bolster a bolster him up say hey
you want a Green Lantern you get Jon
Stewart and nobody else but in this
instance one of the things to remember
and one of the things we talked about
before was Jon Stewart in his younger
days Jon Stewart was a member of the
Marines and then eventually he became a
Green Lantern but when he first became a
Green Lantern he was headstrong he was
arrogant this came to bear with a planet
called zhanchi this this was basically a
planet there was part of this really
weird storyline but the idea is that
there was a bomb in the middle of the
planet and instead of basically keeping
it safe instead of keeping the bomb from
detonating Jon Stewart flew in and tried
to basically defuse it the result was
that the bomb went off killed the planet
and killed everybody on it this is way
Don Jon Stewart's mind ever since and
that's the cool thing about this has
always been a background of his
character and so him being here he's the
only one on this Black Lantern version
of zhanchi that this planet that was
reconstituted by the Black Lantern rings
alongside everybody who was killed but
the cool thing about this is Jon Stewart
is not a guy to be trifled with Jon
Stewart is an absolute beast he
literally just starts creating machine
gun constructs and he unleashes holy
hell on every single one of these black
Lantern's it is pretty amazing but
ultimately Jon Stewart also recognizes
that if he were to continue fighting
this battle on his own he would
assuredly die and if he's taken down by
one of the black Lantern's it'll just
add to their existing ranks
coming back to earth because I know you
guys are really interested in Earth the
Black Lantern Justice League versus
all these different superheroes or at
least whatever's left is actually pretty
impressive because they're all basically
fighting their own personal demons it's
no accident that each of these members
is being you know being pitted against
somebody who they are most familiar with
for example when Hal Jordan became
parallax during the old Emerald Twilight
stories him facing off against Superman
and defeating him has always been
considered an insult to Superman himself
and the rest of the superhero community
now large this was because of the fact
that Hal Jordan as parallax is trying to
obliterate the entirety of the universe
but it was still pretty cool but Barry
Allen grabbing Hal Jordan and racing a
couple seconds into the future basically
allows or at least it means these black
lantern rays that are chasing them are
basically gone because while they are a
couple seconds ahead at the end of the
day in the present moment right then and
there they're gone while all this is
happening Jon Stewart is racing the
earth with an army of all these black
Lantern's behind him so all these things
are basically crescendoing down into
this moment when everybody basically
coalesce is on earth everybody shows up
on earth and it's this massive final
battle the other half of this is that
while these leaders of the various
Lantern cores are able to face off
against some of these threats at the end
of the day the number of black Lantern's
there are almost overwhelming there's
millions of them and so in response to
this ganthet one of the guardians of the
universe one of the guys who helped to
create the Green Lantern Corps comes
along and basically says I'm making
myself a Green Lantern not only that
because of the fact that almost all the
rains are basically built on the very
nature of the Lantern rains themselves a
Green Lantern rings and this is of how
their design how their program what this
means is that each member each each one
of these guys can basically create a
deputy of sorts the ring can duplicate
itself and then go out and find a host
what this does is it allows for a
temporary bolstering of numbers we end
up seeing these rings race off and pick
some amazing house the first one that
gets picked is Lex Luthor and it's the
coolest thing ever because while all
this is going on Lex Luthor's met with
an orange ring of avarice he becomes an
orange lantern scarecrow becomes a
yellow lantern Barry Allen a Blue
Lantern so on and so forth it's one of
the coolest things ever
we get to see characters as men as
various members of the Lantern Corps
that we would normally never see in this
particular scenario and that's why it's
so interesting is because
blackest night was designed to be this
massive story that was huge in scope but
one of the first things that people
started asking when we saw these
introduced
Asians of these different Lantern course
is well what would happen if Superman
became like a Red Lantern or what would
happen if like Wonder Woman became like
a star sapphire best that's the way this
plays out is because it's basically
giving fans their heart's desires here's
what you want to see characters who
would never have a Lantern ring suddenly
get one and then what would they be like
and of course in the middle of all this
we transition basically out to what's
left of the Green Lantern Corps to Kyle
Rayner to ceramic not to the daughter of
Sinestro all these different things now
remember in the last video we talked
about how Kyle Rayner had basically died
how Kyle Rayner as a Green Lantern was
believed to have been dead it took the
combined efforts of one of the star
sapphires the lantern tribe of love to
grab ceramic not to the daughter of
Sinestro who Kyle Rayner I guess who was
in love with Kyle Rayner to basically
tether that life force and bring back
Kyle Rayner to effectively sort of
resurrect him the problem with this is
that in that moment when Kyle Rayner was
dead Guy Gardner of Earth lost it now
here's a funny thing man I love guy
Gardner Guy Gardner fans are a
relatively small mess are the biggest
fan base out there but by god they are
hardcore they lie they love Guy Gardner
and understandably so because Guy
Gardner is like the guy you want in your
corner when the world's going to pot
when it's all going down if I'm somebody
and I'm like okay Who am I gonna pick to
be my Green Lantern who do I want my
corner Guy Gardner because he will fight
until he dies like he's just he is so
awesome and he's so badass for the guys
a former cop you know basically become a
Green Lantern so like he's a no-nonsense
guy in this scenario when he lost his
mind he was suddenly bonded with a Red
Lantern ring now remember when it comes
to the Red Lanterns you don't get to
choose to become one when you get so
full of rage and so full of wrath the
Red Lantern ring just shows up to you
and says you have great rage in your
heart you belong to the Red Lantern
Corps and just forces itself onto you
but this is important because when a
person becomes a Red Lantern their heart
basically gets replaced by the Red
Lantern ring which means to say the Red
Lantern ring becomes their heart their
blood gets your place with plasma if
Kyle Rayner somebody were to walk up and
just take the Red Lantern ring off of
Guy Gardner it would kill him his heart
would basically cease to exist his body
would shut down and that would be the
end of him and so this is basically a
conflict on two fronts as Kyle Rayner
and cirrhotic natsu and the Green
Lantern Corps trying to face off against
the Black Lanterns laws the same time
trying to find a way to bring Guy
Gardner back no none of it really matter
anyway because guy guard or is a red
lantern is wrecking the Black Lantern it
is it's do is one of the coolest things
to see because dude the guy the guy
loses been looking his upcoming action
right here the guy loses his mind on
these black on these black lanterns like
they're doing what they can't but it
doesn't matter man guy you do got garner
freak saucers come come fill that it's
one of the coolest things ever to see
his character freak out like this
because he's just a force of nature like
he's just working through every last one
of these black Lantern's not enough that
he's destroying them in their entirety
and reducing a number by a huge portion
but certainly enough that the black
Lantern's are starting to get a little
concerned now in the middle of all this
we're met with the arrival of Mogo
basically this planet that received a
Green Lantern ring now mogul is one of
the most powerful Green Lantern's out
there just because of the fact that he's
able to put out a massive amount of
power because of its size but mojo is
also like this secondary base of
operations because he's a planet should
Oh the home base of the Green Lantern's
of the guardians of the universe should
it ever be destroyed
no go would become their base of
operations we saw that in the new 52
but what mogul also says is that in this
moment right now there is a protocol
that was devised by the guardians of the
universe that was given to mojo should
ever become an overrun the idea of mojo
is to implement what's called a purge to
effectively purge those who are
intruding in this instance it's the
black Lantern's and so what Mogo does is
basically increase his own gravitational
pull and then grab all every every
single thing within his immediate
vicinity on uh on OA and drag it
directly to where he's at and it brings
them all down to the surface of his own
planet what he does is he basically
grabs these black lanterns and starts
pulling them down into his own core
which is superheated like the core of
any planet and then basically just
starts atomizing them so sure I guess
the Rings are there but their physical
bodies are destroyed and the Razr
useless without a physical body and so
where the day is won so to speak for a
temporary moment what we end up still
having is Guy Gardner as a Red Lantern
and so the question becomes how do you
fix him how do you fix a guy who's a Red
Lantern the only way to really fix a Red
Lantern quote-unquote is to basically
have a Blue Lantern show up and cleanse
their body of the red impurity and then
allow the removal of a ring if a Blue
Lantern is not there there doesn't seem
to be alleged
conceivable way in order to save guy
gardener but there is there is a way to
keep them alive and we'll find out in
the next video without being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end if you
are new here to come this explain make
sure you guys to the sub button to
become part of the rob court if you guys
enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you